everyone has their dreamcast in mind for
any adaptation
and the new netflix show fate the wink
saga is no exception
i'm sure it must be overwhelming an
entirely new world check out our
dreamcast for the upcoming
fate the wink saga while hollywood
castings are done by the professionals
sometimes we can't help but disagree
with the final choices
even if it's a perfect match chances are
there's someone else that would have
been
even better in our minds here's our
choices for the winx saga casting we
wish we could see
while the casting of our heroine seems
spot on we think teen wolf's holland
rhoden would have been perfect
bloom goes through a lot in the first
season she has to adapt to this new
magical world
deal with monsters and peers alike
wanting to destroy her
and trying to figure out her mysterious
past she's frustrated and has a quick
temper if you get angry at me go
away and holland's work on teen wolf
showcased that she could display all the
complex emotions that bloom has
while maintaining the vulnerability of a
young person figuring things out
she is also no stranger to the teen
fantasy horror genre
sydney sweeney would have been a great
choice for stella
stella in the winx saga is cold
mysterious and controlling but
all coming from a place of fear and
false bravado stella has a dark past
that she's trying to run away from
sydney is a pro when it comes to playing
superficially seeming characters who use
appearances to hide their pain
specifically her role as cassie in
euphoria
cassie is considered to be perfect on
the outside but has a lot of darkness
she struggles with
and sydney does a beautiful job which is
why we think she'd make for
a rich and complex stella i think i need
your help
it's okay netflix got it right with
aisha
also known as layla as actress precious
mustafa describes in an interview
she seems quite confident with her
powers but because she's a perfectionist
she doesn't think that's good enough
precious quiet confidence and measured
acting embodies aisha perfectly
but we also think hustler star kiki
palmer
and euphoria star zendaya would have
been excellent picks
kiki started out as a child actress in
projects such as akilah and the bee
zendaya also makes our list because she
can bring immense complexity to any
character
specifically as rue in euphoria for
which she won an
emmy you did this to me
you did this to me ben netflix had no
issue taking liberties with retooling
the original characters
and flora was replaced by a new
character tara aka her cousin
in the live-action series we're sad we
won't see flora but we're hoping she'll
make an appearance in future seasons
singer and actress isabella merced would
be perfect for flora isabella is no
stranger to action roles
given she was in transformers the last
night which would make it easier for her
to jump right in the fight scenes
her work on instant family shows she can
carry emotional weight
i know you feel really sorry for me
right now but you really don't it's got
nothing to do with what just happened
and would be able to fully flesh out
flora and her dynamic with the winx and
her cousins on the live-action show
tara is portrayed by actress elliot sult
we think elliott has done a great job
but stranger things actress shannon
purser would have been wonderful
shannon took a role that could have just
been a throwaway character and gave her
depth and empathy
how can your heart not break for barb
during the swimming pool scene
that was all shannon shannon could bring
a strength and likability to tara
along with giving her a fully developed
backstory you
man musa has sadly been subjected to
whitewashing
a notable asian character is played by
white actress alicia applebaum
in the winx saga honestly dash and lily
star midori francis
would have been excellent her role as
quirky loving and tough lily
proves that she has the skills to bring
empath muse's emotions to the surface
another candidate is lana condor lana's
extensive work in hollywood is exactly
why she'd be great as musa as the
leading lady into all the boys we get to
see lana put her heart on her
character's sleeve in every scene
and that's not easy i need you to know
that i like you peter kavinsky
plus lana has singing chops which is an
added bonus
another character left behind is tekna
rowan blanchard best known for playing
riley matthews on girl meets world
is a perfect casting choice rowan's
guest role on snow piercer
proves that her ability to play bubbly
characters is equally matched with her
ability to be
dark and menacing in a heavy drama
somewhere in the middle of those two
is the wink saga and it would have been
great to watch her utilize those skills
to bring
tekna to life you have about 13 minutes
to agree to a peaceful surrender before
the cold overcomes
sadie soverall who plays beatrix is a
solid sinister combination of the trick
sisters
but someone else who would have been a
great choice is naomi scott
naomi is in movies such as charlie's
angels power rangers and aladdin beatrix
is cunning
seductive highly intelligent and refined
naomi's turn as an international spy
and then as a disney princess is enough
proof that she'd fully flesh out every
aspect of a character as complex
as beatrix possibly taking her more into
an anti-hero like ability than just a
straight-up villain
oh that's creepy it's not that kind of
van everything is that kind of bad
we think anya taylor joy would be an
excellent darcy
darcy's devious and calculated demeanor
is complemented with her intelligence
which anya would nail
anya has become a household name with
her leading role in the queen's gambit
as beth harmon we got to see anya
display an array of emotions with just
one stare from her as
beth anya would be perfect at giving a
richness to a character that because of
her calculatedness
could be seen as a flatter character
you're under my control now
to encapsulate the wicked essence of icy
supermodel and actress kara delevine
would be perfect
kara's dual roles as dr moore
enchantress in suicide squad proves kara
can show vulnerability and fear
along with menacing evil at the drop of
a hat while icy is known as the meanest
of all the tricks
try breaking free from that miss goody
fairy
kara's ability to show slivers of
emotion in a stone-cold evil character
could bring a level of humanity and
intrigue to a role that could be easy to
play as a one note character
rounding out the tricks trio is sister
stormy maisie williams could bring the
wild child stormi to a whole new level
stormy's unpredictability and zest for
evil could be hard for an actor to make
into a realistic feeling character
but for eight seasons maisie took ayah
stark from young
feisty tomboy to full-on assassin
maisie's measured cold portrayal of aya
had moments of levity and her ability to
ground every scene she was in
is exactly what stormy would need to
balance her loose canon personality
casting newcomer danny griffin was the
perfect choice for the king of araclian
although ross lynch would have also been
great ross is known for his work as
harvey on sabrina where he does a tricky
balance of being a teen heartthrob and
making harvey well-rounded
that's the balance that needs to be
struck with sky and with ross's acting
chops on full display as serial killer
jeffrey dahmer he's proven he can bring
the charm and the skill to give skye the
complexity he needs
never say those words again or i will
rush you myself
next up is fun-loving brandon who
doesn't make an appearance in the wink
saga if they ever bring brandon in later
seasons the kissing booth and euphoria
star jacob belordy is a dead ringer
jacob's dark role as nate in euphoria is
very compelling
having that kind of emotional pull and
skill level would add a lot to the
reimagining of brandon
even with him being a much lighter
character originally and these flowers
are so
beautiful not as beautiful as you
smart and shy timmy is also missing from
the live-action adaptation
but if he ever makes an appearance later
on riverdale's kj
apa would be perfect kj is known for his
role as the athletic archie but his work
on riverdale shows he's actually not too
far off from the sensitive sweet
specialist
kj can lead an ensemble cast and attain
melodrama for several seasons
as his growth as archie has proven this
is the best last day of summer a guy
could ask for freddie thorpe makes a
great riven in the adaptation
however ki hong li would have been
perfect riven is known to be a bit of a
lone wolf
athletic and very competitive we've
gotten to see kihong as a selfless and
hardworking best friend
and a full-blown action star in the maze
runner he also has shown off his
romantic and sensitive side as kimmy's
love interest in unbreakable kimmy
schmidt
riven has a lot going on emotionally and
kihong would pull all of it off with
excellence
i can't pretend i don't have feelings
for you anymore we think oscar winner
tilda swinton would have made an
excellent ferraganda a veteran and
skilled actress with chameleon-like
abilities to disappear behind her
characters she would have had an
interesting take on the headmistress
specifically thinking of her role in the
lion the witch and the wardrobe as the
evil manipulative white witch
if it's a war iceland wants
it's a war he shall get well viewers we
had a lot of fun reimagining our dream
cast
that's our hot take on who we would
recast in fate the winx saga
do our choices align with yours or do
you have other actors in mind
let us know in the comments